good morning long time no see uh
it's been a while since my last video um
so if you're new here my name is
christian shafer i am an outdoor
adventure photographer and i've been
living on the road full time
for almost three years it'll be three
years in may and i live in
my campervan so i am currently staying
in a in a house in a small mountain town
in colorado in the rockies
so it's only for a couple weeks but i've
had the opportunity to go through my
footage
and um kind of collect pieces of what's
been going on the last couple months so
i'm excited to share that with you guys
and yeah let's just pick up right where
we left off in
the arizona desert
[Music]
got a crack in the windshield today
probably from the change in temperature
trying to fix it with a little
windshield repair kit
we'll see if it works also hard because
it's raining today
well i just supplied the
resin to try to fix the crack and now
it's hailing
so that probably won't work
it's a winter weather advisory here in
tucson we went to a state campground but
it's just a dirt lot and the sand was
kind of soft already and since it's
supposed to rain there were signs
everywhere that said
prone to flooding may stay flooded for
days so
i don't know where i'm going to spend
the night this doesn't happen that often
but when it does it's
kind of a bummer
[Music]
all right so i made it to a walmart
parking lot and it's actually pretty
chill here there's quite a few rvs and
vans
and trailers so i feel safe i feel like
no one's going to come knocking
just made some pasta so tonight's pretty
low-key just gonna
snuggle under the covers watch some
netflix
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
you're so cute my turn now
like all the national forests were
closed in oregon like in
in may i think
oh there's like freaking it really does
look like a coffee latte i
am about to go get my hair
professionally colored which i actually
haven't done since
college which was back in like 2005 or
2006
so i'm a little nervous i've had blonde
hair for the longest longest time
you can see my roots are growing in and
i'm going to get some
darker lowlights coming through here and
i'm going to try to get back to my
natural color
i would have loved to do this sooner but
it's a little
expensive to have low lights done and
since i move around all the time
i didn't really have a hair stylist to
go see consistently so i've been putting
it off
and it's still pretty blonde but
hopefully after a few more treatments
it'll get darker and darker
[Music]
ah
[Music]
okay so why did i head to san diego well
as some of you pointed out in my last
video
i really needed some new tires in
phoenix i tried upgrading to a set of
more rugged 245 ko2's but
they were too big for the promaster 225
is the recommended tire size which is
slightly smaller than the 245s
so the rear fenders needed to be custom
cut landed gear had an opening that week
and they gave my van a whole new look
sumo springs for better suspension a
spare tire mount new set of 245 ko2's
new rims and they even installed an s
bar heater in the van
i had an interview at the new york times
in san diego that week so the timing was
perfect
and they had really cute dogs
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that made it all possible you guys are
amazing
and no dogs these guys are the helpers
[Music]
do
[Laughter]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you
all right so i just pulled over found a
cool place to just hang out relax and
the view is really nice
um i'm gonna fire up the heater and make
some hot tea
maybe read for a little bit i haven't
had a heater like this whole time
not in the van or the suv unless you
count the actual car heater
so this is a pretty big game changer for
me um
so yeah i'm excited to show you guys
that all right so the heater lives
beneath my passenger seat so anytime i
want to use it
i just unhook my guitar and move it
which is good because i might actually
play it more often this heater is the
gas petrol version
so it draws fuel directly from my gas
tank it's really efficient it hardly
uses any gas at all
and i don't have to worry about
refilling a separate gas tank
i got my heater from heatso which is a
great resource if you're in the market
for
any kind of heater for your van rv or
boat i turn the heater on using this
controller up here which is wired
directly to my house battery and runs on
the 12 volt dc
system so it uses very little power i
can set the temperature here and once
the air starts blowing it gets hot
fast so the ventilation for the heater
is right down here
it's where the exhaust comes out it's
getting hot
also i picked up a few things for the
van now that i have a heater just to be
safe a carbon monoxide detector which i
still need to install
and a couple cans of fire extinguisher
i've only had the heater on for four
minutes and already the van is way too
hot
so i had to turn it off and on a cold
night if i throw up my
insulated window covers the whole van
will just be nice and toasty with that
running for a little bit
so it's definitely a nice change
[Music]
if
[Music]
i
[Music]
if you you
want to make a home again
[Music]
[Music]
again
i'm still trying to find
i'm still trying to find a way to say